let's think about a car just the car
okay now what I want to do my real
problem here is that I have time and
distances and they're not really
connected appropriately see this 40 km/h
thats related to time but this 40 is not
connected to time it's just it's a
particular instance in the situation I
think you out in fact this number this
number really should not be on my
diagram at all okay at least look the
way that they are at the moment that
kind of implies that that's 40 all the
time and that's birdie all the time
that's not useful it's not a helpful way
to label this diver I want this diagram
to account for change so we're going to
do that it's the think about this guy
now it's getting bigger isn't it okay
it's getting bigger every hour that
passes it gets bigger by 40 right let's
figure my for you so for instance
something I can call this this distance
up here is for TT every time an hour
passes it gets 40 times bigger right I
don't know 40 times bigger itself but in
40 8130 and so on okay so that's a good
place to start this is much better
calling a 40 t as much better than koya
40 because this thing's changing which
we know what we know it's changing okay
good but there's a problem with this
right which is that at time zero where
is the car now I can invent what times
zero is right but I might as well call
it the starting point which is when it's
40 kilometers away right so to account
for that i will add 40 right so it'll
start at 40 then will be an 8120 hundred
sixty rather than siding zero and then
for you and so on okay so i'm calling
this leg here round calling it for TT
plus 40 right therefore give me a name
for the other leg
52 plus de right to account for number
one its speed and number two its
starting position ok now what I've just
done verbally is kind of what you would
do by integration so if you want to if
you wanted to try and go with this right
if i want to go from this for instance
to get a statement for us call that
capital circle ok well i could integrate
couldn't I I could integrate this sorry
we just make the team which would give
me this right but of course you would
give for TT plus a constant aha how do
we get rid this constant initial
conditions and you would get your 40 and
you would get your 30 okay now this is a
much better way to go ok now when i call
this X ok what i call this head because
i have so much fewer variables flying
around right i'm not going to write into
this problem though how do i rephrase
what in terms of what then what do i
differentiate in terms of what and so on
ok what would i do here i guess i would
say from Pythagoras right the x squared
is equal to a sum of the squares of the
two shorter site
okay cool
thank you you can turn off that no
thanks I've got an expression for X it's
in terms of time whoa wait a second this
is really good because remember i said
there's nothing wrong over the side
right it's just awkward but what i
wanted right this can almost jump out
directly at me i don't need to worry
about these guys anymore because I
phrase them in terms of time from the
beginning does that make sense so it's
kind of like a related rates question
well it is related rates questions okay
but you don't have to phrase it that way
there are no related rates here anymore
I just have X and time okay so let's
work with this what am I going to get
I'll really get 1600 T squared plus
3,200 t + 1600 yeah I check it when I
got here 2500 T squared that's it dinner
3000t and 900 hmm I've just written on a
tree lines to make the collection of my
toes easier collect everything 40 100 of
these 60 200 of these and 2500 of these
that's a square ok I can now get an
expression for X and I'm going to do two
things at once I'm going to take the
square root and I'm also going to take
out the obvious factor excuse me of 110
squared right so if you turn out the
front at this of course since i've only
taken the positive value i want to
explain why but i can say x is 0 it's a
length
ok now this point I don't need to fuss
around with any chain rule which is what
i was looking for before because i have
just X in terms of T we have X as a
function of time so i can just
differentiate this is to the power of
half hmm who do this in our heads the
half will come out the front that will
become a five right it will go on the
denominator because it become negative
half so that'll be this but of course I
also need to do the inside function not
just the outside what's the derivative
of the inside function it looks like a t
to t plus 62 yes okay they asked us for
a particular moment I'm namely our for
an hour teasing hours isn't it I don't
need to find it but you can tell it's
all yours so I say led to equal one DX
over DT I believe you end up getting 720
on the square root of hundred
twenty-eight when you stick one into all
of these tees okay so it's great up in
genera what's the biggest square number
you can get on that means 64 and I think
that's how many 64 is is there
sorry it's how many eighths is in math
isn't it which is which is 90 plug we're
not that big a deal about rationalizing
that kind of thing British it happens in
new case I mean that's a factor of two
isn't it so you might as well like this
okay and then you conclude 45 root 2
km/h at that instant can you see again
the calculus is not high it's all in the
framing right once you get that right it
just it literally plops out not to
mention it if you frame it right
changing the question a little bit
doesn't throw you off ok the next
question will the next part it says at
what rate with the distance between them
be changing at that instant if they were
both traveling toward the intersection
rather than away ok think about it i've
crafted my equations very well so that
they will account for such a change very
easily what will be different if they
were going the other way it should not
be 40 t / sporty with this derivative
here it should be it should be going
this way right the length is getting
smaller so therefore this should really
be negative for TT + 40 still started at
the same place and this should be
negative 50 t plus 30 how is that going
to change my jury reduced as I go
through okay because there will be a
negative sign here and here right it
doesn't change these two terms of these
two terms does it because they've been
squared right it changes these two this
will be a negative and that'll be a
negative so instead of plus 6200 t I'll
get negative which means don't get
negative there which means I'll get a
negative here and here and then you can
sub it the value you will get DX on duty
I believe it's a hundred on the square
root of thing I think check out the
numbers which of course is to that gives
you 15 tada
so what have we learned okay when you
draw a diagram yes put on your
information but don't just do it blindly
okay don't think okay 40 here 50 there
are 49 30 and then so on right think
about carefully how to build the rates
of change into your diagram and
therefore into your equations because
it's simplifying it so dramatically so
we're fighting the steps so the coaches
okay all right I leave that up there
just in case something you've not copied
it down yet but I think it's a really
good question because it has related
rate if you don't need to think about it
that way okay and this is really really
this is a really really useful way to
approach the kinds of links or volumes
or whatever but you have changing one
okay